[موسيقى]
اخبار العالم بايجاز من غرفه اخبار
الجزيره اهلا بكم في اول قراراتها بشان
دعوى جنوب افريقيا باتهام اسرائيل بارتكاب
اباده جماعيه ضد الفلسطينيين في غزه محكمه
العدل الدوليه تطالب اسرائيل باتخاذ جميع
الاجراءات لمنع الاباده الجماعيه وبضمان
توفير الاحتياجات الانسانيه في غزه فورا
وتطلب منها رفع تقرير للمحكمه خلال شهر
بشان تبير المؤقته وتجدون المزيد من اخبار
حرب غزه في رابط بالتعليق الاول وكاله
رويترز تنقل عن اربعه مصادر ايرانيه
ودبلوماسي مطلع ان مسؤولين صينيين طلبوا
من نظرائهم الايرانيين المساعده في كبح
هجمات الحوثيين على السفن في البحر الاحمر
والا فان ضررا قد يلحق بالعلاقات التجاريه
مع بيكين الرئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان
يوقع المرسوم الرئاسي بشان انض امام
السويد الى النيتو ويوافق على البروتوكول
ض الصله به لتكون الخطوه الفنيه الاخيره
في مسار مصادقه تركيا على انضمام السويد
للحلف الاطلسي القيمه السوقيه لاسهم شركه
مايكروسوفت تتخطى حاجز الثلاثه ترليونات
دولار للمره الاولى لتحتفظ بمكانتها كثاني
اكبر شركه في العالم من حيث القيمه بعد
ابل وفي تطور لاحق اعلنت مايكروسوفت تسريح
1000 و900 موظف في قطاع الالعاب
الالكترونيه الى
اللقاء